und wir kommen zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es um die ukraine krise bzw um
die möglichen ernährungs engpässe die
preise steigen das über hier natürlich
heute auch immer schon ein thema die
ukraine ist einer der grössten getreide
lieferanten weltweit das getreide kann
aber nicht geerntet werden wenn es schon
geerntet wurde kann es nicht aus der
ukraine gebracht werden das ist ein
problem eine ernährungskrise droht union
die unions fraktion sowie die fdp
fraktion haben jeweils anträge
eingereicht und fordern jeweils auf ihre
art dagegen vorzugehen erste rednerin
ist allerdings von der grünen-fraktion
anne monika spallek
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen jeden tag
wenn wir die nachrichten verfolgen sehen
wir unfassbares leid familien waren
mehrere kinder um angehörige um ihre
heimat und viele wissen nicht wann und
ob sie wieder zu essen bekommen in der
ukraine in den kriegsgebieten aber auch
weltweit wir sehen brennende ukrainische
weizenfelder zerstörte lagerhallen
bombardierte transportwege und genauso
sehen wir aber auch in indien unfassbare
hitze überschwemmungen im zweitgrößten
anbauland für weizen und wir sehen auch
menschen die sich am horn von afrika auf
den weg in eine neue heimat machen weil
sie in ihrem land aufgrund von dürren
sonst verhungern würden und gleichzeitig
sehen wir börsen preise für weizen die
auf dem höchsten stand der geschichte
schnell
all diese bilder sind kaum zu ertragen
und sie lebend fast meinen verstand aber
wir dürfen uns nicht lähmen lassen und
einsam schnellschüsse machen wir müssen
alle krisen zusammen denken und das ist
jetzt unsere verantwortung das heißt
auch frei von allen fossilen
energieträgern
wir müssen
wir müssen jetzt den mut haben uns
unsere eigenen verstandes zu bedienen
wie es schon immanuel kant an mahnte sie
aber meine damen und herren von der
cdu/csu schlagen mit der kompletten
aufhebung der vierprozentigen
stilllegung eine rolle rückwärts vor als
gäbe es keine biodiversitäts und keine
klimakrise sie wollen ernsthaft alte
brachen wieder um brechen was wiederum
eine erhebliche co2 ausstoß nach sich
ziehen würde und sie wollen ernst sagt
auf ertragsschwachen biodiversitäts
massenhaft teuren dünger verwenden damit
dort minimal weizen wächst und sie
wollen ernsthaft und sie wollen
ernsthaft die für die biodiversität so
wichtigen hecken und landschaftselemente
roden lassen den bogen rackern und damit
dünner weizen nein das würde nicht viel
helfen sondern mehr schaden und da waren
sich die experten in der anhörung auch
einig
und es gibt ja klügere lösung und die
gehen wir bereits an und da bin ich
unseren ministerin auch sehr sehr
dankbar wir wollen den einsatz von
nahrungs und futtermitteln für
biokraftstoffe schnell senken bis 20 30
auf 0 und bereits 20 23 sollen so 1,6
1,1 hektar anbauflächen frei werden das
sind 4,2 millionen tonnen weizen wir
haben das fruchtwechsel gebot um ein
jahr verschoben dass wir wieder mehrere
millionen tonnen weizen möglich macht
und vor allem leiten wir mit der
ernährung strategie und dem umbau der
tierhaltung langfrist maßnahmen denn
wenn wir weniger fleisch essen brauchen
wir viel weniger futter anbauflächen und
dazu ist es noch erheblich gesünder und
in ihrem antrag lese ich darüber gar
nichts und fakt ist doch es gab davor
die krise schon hungernde achten und 100
mio
lassen sie uns doch besser jetzt
gemeinsam an beruhigungsmittel zum
integrierten differenzierten lösungen
arbeiten die die residenz fähigkeit der
agra systeme insgesamt und auch die
selbst versorgungsquote in den regionen
damit lade ich sie ein
vielen dank frau wilding spalek
die story kollege dieter stier cdu csu
fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren wir beraten heute einen antrag
der unionsfraktionen welcher zügiges
handeln und
kluger überlegungen vorausschauende
überlegungen eng miteinander verbindet
um in einer sehr schwierigen lage
gerecht zu werden der krieg in der
ukraine
und davon kann man europas versagt nicht
nur ein vielfaches an menschlichen leid
sondern eher gefährdet auch die
ukrainische landwirtschaft
und er hat international erhebliche
auswirkungen auf unsere agrarmärkte die
bitteren folgen da sind sich alle
beobachter einig werden wir in den
nächsten monaten erst noch deutlich zu
spüren bekommen blockierte häfen
knappheit bei diesel und düngemitteln
zerstörte technik die kriegsbedingten
schäden allein im ukrainischen
agrarsektor belaufen sich gegenwärtig
bereits als 6,4 milliarden us dollar so
die berechnungen der
welternährungsorganisation der vereinten
nationen die folgen für die import
abhängigen länder sind noch nicht
bezifferbar das getreide defizit auf den
weltmärkten trifft die abnehmer im nahen
osten sowie in nord und ostafrika
besonders dort lieber ne mauretanien
tunesien dschibuti hängen fast
vollständig von den einfuhren als der
ukraine ab somalia und eritrea immer
noch zur hälfte nur wer jetzt sofort
entschieden handelt meine damen und
herren der kann da drunten
hungerkatastrophe noch etwas
substanzielles entgegensetzen
jeder beitrag zählt die zeit läuft und
sie läuft gegen uns die versorgungskrise
kann jedoch durch eine einfache
weichenstellung recht schnell zumindest
abgemildert werden die lösung liegt auf
der hand da sofortige stopp der
zwangsstilllegung von vier prozent
unserer agrarflächen
die sich stilllegungs schlicht meine
damen und herren muss über das sie muss
aufgehoben werden und ich sage ihnen sie
würden sonst 20 23 zur großen ampel
hypothek dem ideologischen hemmnis bei
der bekämpfung der hungerkrise eine
flächen freigabe bedeutet so ahlers die
versorgung zur stabilisierung bedeutet
zusätzlich bis zu einer million tonnen
weizen verfügbar zu machen allein in
deutschland europa noch nicht
mitgerechnet und ja ich kenne auch ihre
kritik der ertrags haben wir gerade
gehört zeit auch viel zu geringen ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein vielleicht
werden es nur 600.000 können nein in der
aktuellen situation müssen wir für jeden
ertrag jeden cent den wir obendrauf
sammeln können dankbar sein gerade wenn
er durch eine schnelle entscheidung
erreicht auch mit neuen
züchtungsmethoden davon der fdp benannte
sachverständige professor klein hat sich
in der öffentlichen anhörung am montag
nach meiner wahrnehmung nachdrücklich
dafür ausgesprochen hören sie einfach
auf
doch anstatt alles zu mobilisieren was
machbar ist und diese chance zu nutzen
vorhabt die ampel regierung bockig und
ignorant und ihrer schmollecke und will
nichts davon wissen ihre verweigerung
frau staatssekretärin der minister es ja
leider nicht da ist falsch
ungenutzte zwangs stillgelegte flächen
also brachflächen bei einer
hungerkatastrophe als nicht verhandelbar
zu deklarieren ist nicht nur zynisch
gegenüber den betroffenen in den
entwicklungsländern es ist auch ein
angriff auf die humanitären grundsätzen
unserer modernen gesellschaft
und uns dann unaufrichtigkeit in dieser
sache vorzuwerfen nur weil wir ihren job
machen und echte lösungen aufzeigen dass
vor deutlich das ausmaß der verzweiflung
mit ihrem selbst geschaffenen dilemma
anständig umzugehen an der stilllegung
festzuhalten dieser aktuellen notlage
ist und bleibt unverantwortlich andere
und sie legen still nur und fern vom
hunger alltag in afrika ihre abstrakten
ökologischen und ideologischen fantasien
zu befriedigen
das kann in unserer aktuellen situation
doch nicht richtig sein und das wissen
sie auch genau meine damen und herren
ich stelle heute hier an diesen kult
abschließend fest sie wollen keinen
verantwortungsvollen beitrag leisten wir
schulden sie wollen ausbremsen wir
wollen beschleunigen und weil wir jetzt
jedes potenzial nutzen müssen haben wir
ihnen den passgenauen antrag hier
mitgebracht und abschließend noch ein
wort zu ihrem oral zur welt moral da
grün und meine damen und herren ich
finde dass es ein ernstes thema es ist
traurig dass sie den hungernden menschen
offenbar schon aufgegeben haben sie
sagen die freigabe der flächen das
bringt sowieso nichts lassen wir das
einfach getreu dem motto die paar leute
die wir satt machen können fallen doch
nicht ins gewicht was ist das für ein
menschenbild meine damen
vollkommen unverständlich für mich
offensichtlich auch für ihre eigenen
wählerinnen und wähler nicht immer zu
ertragen denn bei den rettungsaktionen
im mittelmeer legen sie selbst stets
allergrößten wert auf jedes
einzelschicksal bei der hungerkrise
dagegen ist es ihnen vollkommen egal ob
auch nur ein einziger mensch mehr sagt
wertungsflüge dieser
doppelmoral
diese botschaft der missachtung ihrer
eigenen maßstäbe könnte nicht schlimmer
sein sie wir haben die verantwortung
meine damen und herren wir
stimmen heute auch namentlich ab sie
können sich alle bekennen in welches
lager sie gehören vielen dank
22 m maßnahmen schlägt die unions
fraktion in ihrem antrag
forum gegen die ernährungsunsicherheit
vorzugehen
auch die durch die antworten wird nun
rita hagl kehl für die spd-fraktion die
kolleginnen und kollegen
putin führt einen krieg in europa und
verstößt damit nicht nur gegen das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der ukraine
sondern er setzt auch hunger gezielt als
waffe ein und trifft damit die ärmsten
dieser welt
das welternährungsprogramm schätzt die
erhöhung der hungernden auf circa 47
millionen menschen der antrag der cdu
csu versucht dass hierauf zugreifen
sie fordern unter anderem maßnahmen
im bereich der entwicklungshilfe diese
maßnahmen dieses sofortprogramm ist
bereits unterwegs also sie kommen etwas
zu später mit wir haben ja heute auf die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin aus
dem bmz hier sitzen die kann ihnen das
alles noch mal erklären ich versuche
jetzt auch einmal auf dem g7-treffen das
eben gestern gestartet hat soll eben der
startschuss für ein bündnis führung war
für einige globales entwicklungs
sicherheitspaket geschnürt werden
außerdem hat die bundesregierung bereits
1 430 millionen sofort paket geschnürt
unter anderem mit aufbau sozialer
sicherungssysteme
basis dienstleistungen im bereich
gesundheit und bildung
wasserversorgung fördern und klima
angepasst der landwirtschaft und
ernährungssicherung am horn von afrika
damit verfolgen wir ein ziel nämlich
nicht dass deutschland die welt ernähren
muss sondern dass wir die welt bewegen
dass sie sich selbst ernähren kann
und dieses
in dieses konzept passt auch die sonder
initiative eine welt ohne hunger mit 150
millionen euro dabei wird zb
bereitstellung von betriebsmitteln wie
saatgut und dünger und beratung von
landwirtinnen und landwirten gefördert
das kabinett hatte außerdem am 27.04
beschlossen zusätzliche mittel für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in höhe von
einer milliarde euro zu bewilligen das
parlament berät gerade darüber aber
lassen sie mich noch auf ein paar punkte
ihres antrags eingehen die hier gerade
so ausführlich erklärt hat zb auf den
punkt 13 mehr pflanzenschutzmittel auf
ökologischen vorrangflächen sie glauben
anscheinend die landwirte wollen da
setzt sagt zeige ich ihnen das beispiel
einer ostbayerischen molkerei auf die
auch übrigens sehr gut exportiert zum
beispiel ein toll mozzarella di haben
vor jahren
verboten für ihre milchbauern vor vier
wochen haben sie beschlossen das
erlauben wir jetzt wieder was glauben
sie was passiert ist ein aufschrei
unserer milchbauern und bäuerinnen die
wollen dass glyphosat nicht mehr
verwenden sie blicken auch genau
dahinter was hier eigentlich dahinter
steckt nämlich damit kann man den
milchpreis wieder senken gleichzeitig
kostet dass glyphosat noch zusätzlich
geld also ist auch noch mal schwieriger
in der anschaffung und
und was dazu kommt
wir haben hauptsächlich grünland als
macht auch gar keinen zünder punkt 18
uhr mesz an max modernen
züchtungsmethoden hat ja stöhr genannt
nennen sie es doch das kind beim namen
es geht um gentechnik die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher in
deutschland wollen keine gentechnik auf
unsere landwirte lehnen das ab punkt 20
ausweitung der sozialversicherungs
freien beschäftigung für
saisonarbeitskräfte
damit kommen sie jedes jahr an die
letzten zwei jahre war wohl der grund
jetzt ist der grund sonst können die
ernten nicht eingebracht werden von obst
gemüse und sonderkulturen also sie
wollen mir erklären also wenn die
saisonarbeitskräfte nach 70 tagen an
sozialversicherungspflichtig werden dann
kann man nichts mehr einbringen der
ernte also sie unterstellen den
landwirten sie haben zu viel angebaut
und dann kann es nicht mehr eingebracht
werden also jedes jahr eine neue
begründung die irgendwie sehr
fadenscheinig ist punkt 21
fahrten mit einem gesamtgewicht von 44
tonnen sollen jetzt bis 150 kilometer
erlaubt sein dass man dafür sehr viel
diesel braucht zu 44 tonnen zu bewegen
das weiß ich aus der eigenen familie des
ist kostet einiges an diesel und diesel
ist ja gerade auch so günstig geworden
also das heißt höhere energiekosten für
die landwirtinnen und landwirten aber
dafür haben sie im punkt 22 dann die
lösung mit finanziellen entlastungen
gegen die verteuerung dass man damit
auch den co2 ausstoß fördert ist ihnen
eigentlich ganz egal wie heizen damit
nochmal den klimawandel an und auch dem
die erde ja leider keine scheibe ist
sondern eine kuh betrifft das wieder die
ärmsten der armen
damit haben sie das ziel das wir
eigentlich verfolgen müssten alle
zusammen nämlich die globale eher näher
sicherheit im einklang mit klimaschutz
und biodiversität
unter einen hut zu bringen total
verfehlt deswegen linien und jakob
dankeschön
die fdp fraktion hat einen antrag
eingereicht in dem sie sich mit den
kosten für die landwirte
beschäftigt unter anderem mit den kosten
für düngemittel und für die afg fraktion
spricht nun frank erringt
herr präsident werte kollegen wir stehen
vor der nächsten großen krise einer
krise bei der die versorgungssicherheit
mit lebensmitteln auch in deutschland
auf dem spiel steht und es keinen platz
mehr für ideologische oder weltfremde
fantasien geben kann die versorgung mit
nahrungsmitteln in unserem land muss
sichergestellt sein
die afb fordert eine pflanzen gerechte
düngung um möglichst hohe erträge von
guter qualität auf unseren heimischen
feldern zu erzeugen meine damen und
herren dies sollte eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein aber leider
war die politik in diesem hohen haus in
den letzten jahren und besonders seit
der bildung der ampel regierung er
darauf bedacht unsere bauern zur aufgabe
ihrer betriebe und höfe zu bringen und
unsere landwirtschaft abzubauen
damit muss nun schluss sein wir können
uns so eine verantwortungslose politik
nicht länger leisten wir müssen die
versorgung unserer bevölkerung
sicherstellen und darüber hinaus müssen
wir auch in der lage sein wirtschaftlich
schwächere länder mit nahrungsmitteln
exporten zu unterstützen um
fluchtbewegungen nach europa vorzubeugen
diese
erfordert natürlich wie in unserem
antrag beschrieben eine intensive
landwirtschaft und fläche mit pflanzen
gerechtem düngereinsatz und kein mangel
und unterversorgung wie es die regierung
anstrebt eine weitere verringerung
unserer produktion würde zudem die
preise zu lasten der bevölkerung weiter
ansteigen lassen bei der derzeitigen
inflation ist dies kaum noch tragbar für
die menschen in unserer heimat
zum cdu-antrag sei gesagt dass wir bei
diesem mitgehen können schön wäre es
gewesen liebe kollegen wenn sie wie
beispielsweise in punkt 11 wo gefordert
ist dass die vier prozent der
flächenstilllegung 823 aufzuheben ist
mehr als auf solche punkte eingegangen
werden nun dies haben sie es leider
nicht aber in anbetracht der lage dieser
punkt ist genau richtig und darum
unterstützen wie ihren antrag
dünger ist leider ein bisschen
untergegangen bei ihnen darum haben wir
aber ein antrag bei gestellt zum glück
sind wir in diesem haus vertreten
vergangenen montag in der öffentlichen
anhörung wurde ja auch ganz klar dass
wir im bereich der dünne versorgung ein
großes defizit zu erwarten haben und die
bundesregierung auch dort ihre
hausaufgaben leider wieder einmal nicht
macht der stellvertretende
generalsekretär des deutschen
bauernverbandes emmerling legte sehr
eindrucksvoll dar dass die
nährstoffversorgung in deutschland nicht
allein mit organischen dünger
gewährleistet ist und dass die
mineraldünger versorgung kritisch sei
völlig klar dass wir auf die experten
hören sollten und unmittelbar die
versorgung mit dünger sicherstellen
müssen so wie in unserem antrag
gefordert
werte kollegen aus der regierung kümmern
sie sich um die dünger versorgung und um
zuverlässige lieferanten da aus russland
und der ukraine nicht mit mineraldünger
zu rechnen ist
wir müssen unsere landwirtschaft
krisenfest machen und das nicht
irgendwann sondern jetzt
herr minister leider sind sie ja nicht
anwesend aber ich gehe mal davon aus
dass sie dieser debatte auch in der
ferne folgen überdenken sie außerdem
bitte wie sie mit unseren landwirten
umgehen unsere bauern sind keine
radikalen ränder sondern die mitte der
gesellschaft und garantieren unsere
versorgung mit lebensmitteln die
deutschen landwirte haben die weisheit
auch nicht mit löffeln gefressen sondern
haben eine fundierte praxisbezogene
ausbildung gemacht fordere unseren
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister hier und
heute auch auf sich bei den landwirten
die ada beschimpft hat zu entschuldigen
und sich in zukunft lieber mit
wirklichen problemen der deutschen
landwirtschaft zu beschäftigen anstatt
unsere land zu beschimpfen vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
ist nicht so genau das wollte ich der
kollegen kubot die fdp fraktion
ja ja der präsident sehr geehrte damen
und herren
der krieg in der ukraine hat und
schlagartig die schwachstellen und
abhängigkeiten bei der
lebensmittelversorgung vor augen geführt
ertragsausfälle in der kornkammer
ukraine
explodierende lebensmittel und dinge
preise aus und energiekosten der
flaschenhals transportweg in der
öffentlichen anhörung des ausschusses am
montag haben uns die experten die
dramatischen folgen dieses käses dieser
krise sehr deutlich vor augen geführt
das ergebnis der anhörung war unstreitig
wir brauchen mittel und langfristig
höhere erträge auf denen nur begrenzt
verfügbaren ackerflächen
aber absteigen doch nicht zu lasten der
umwelt durch den einsatz von mehr dünger
und mehr pflanzenschutzmittel noch
folgen wir müssen produktivität
versorgungssicherheit und
umweltfreundlichkeit
zusammenbringen
dieser spagat gelingt nur dann wenn wir
auch unsere technischen errungenschaften
sinnvollen nutzen als fdp stehen wir für
technologieoffenheit innovationen
deshalb setzen wir auf grüne
biotechnologie in der landwirtschaft
mit hilfe von neuen züchtungsmethoden
können wir in der landwirtschaft
deutlich ertragsreicher und und diese
umweltfreundlicher machen wir müssen die
potenziale der gentechnik für eine
effiziente produktion
mit weniger einsatz von chemie nutzen
deutschland als einer wichtigsten
industrie- und biotechnologie standorte
könnte damit einen wichtigen beitrag zu
einer effizienten und
gleichzeitig nachhaltigen
lebensmittelproduktion leisten diese
technologie offenheit und weitsicht in
bezug auf
zukunftsweisende innovation vermisse ich
im vorliegenden unionsantrag
erlauben sie mir noch einen hinweis
die gängige bezeichnung gen manipulation
für zu dieser wird dieser
zukunftsweisenden technologie nicht
gerecht kommen sie zum schluss für ihn
vielmehr sollten wir von ihnen
optimierung reden ein unionsantrag
lehnen wir ab vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege locken und
nächste rednerin ist in latendorf die
sprecherin für landwirtschaft ländliche
räume und tierschutz der linksfraktion
im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kollegen und kolleginnen
die welthungerhilfe sagt bis zum jahr
2030 kann und soll der hunger weltweit
beendet werden eine ungerechte
verteilung von ressourcen steht diesem
ziel bisher im wege politik wissenschaft
wirtschaft gesellschaft und
zivilgesellschaftliche organisationen
müssen ihr zusammenspiel verbessern bis
zu 800 elf millionen hungernden menschen
haben ein recht darauf
zitat ende
davon sagt der antrag der unionsfraktion
nichts klar ist die unzureichende welt
werden weltweite
nahrungsmittelversorgung wird sich durch
den krieg in der ukraine weiter
dramatisch verschärfen aber die
generelle krise der welternährung ist
nicht neu regionale strukturen die
regionale versorgung ist in vielen
bereichen zerstört wurden deutlich
sichtbar ist dass dort wo menschen
hungern aber auf den feldern stadt hirse
und mais rosen für die supermärkte in
europa wachsen und was ist die ursache
profitieren und das haben die
regierungen der letzten jahrzehnte
mitgemacht und zu verantworten die
sachverständigen haben diese anhörung
aus meiner sicht der motor ganz deutlich
bestätigt es wurde nach der krise 2008
so weitergemacht wie zuvor und nichts
geändert
fakt ist vor der pandemie war die zahl
hungernder menschen laut fao anhaltend
hoch die hauptursache hierfür sind armut
soziale ungleichheit kriege gewaltsame
konflikte sowie die klimakrise und schon
vor ausbruch des krieges waren zehn
prozent der weltbevölkerung unter
ernährt jeder dritte mensch hatte keinen
zugang zu gesunder ernährung schuld
daran ist global gesehen aber nicht eine
zu niedrige produktion sondern der
mangelnde zugang die einkommen sind
einfach zu niedrig und es gibt große
einkommensunterschiede
es fehlt also soziale gerechtigkeit
der börsen getriebene erhebliche
preisanstieg für lebensmittel wird den
hunger in der ärmsten in den ärmsten
regionen der welt verschärfen die
durchschnittliche verteuerung dann
lebensmitteln lag vom märz zu april 2022
bereits 30 prozent das liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen hat aber nichts mit
angezogenen nachfrage zu tun dennoch ist
das angebot da
die hungernden und von hunger bedrohten
menschen in dieser welt werden gewisse
nie verstehen wie man auf eventuelle
preisentwicklung von lebensmitteln
wetten abschließen kann um gewinn zu
erzielen und das ist eine perverse form
der spielaktionen
maßnahmen zur eindämmung der aktuellen
preis sowie die ernährungskrise dürfen
nicht gegen klimakrise und soziale
ungleichheit ausgespielt werden aber
gerade das lese ich in diesem antrag es
geht um die welternährung aber sie
blicken nur auf die europäische und
deutsche landwirtschaft ohne wirklich
nachhaltige globale lösung anzubieten
und das ist kurzsichtig
stärken von regeln ein
wirtschaftskreisläufen indien von 100
betroffenen region ist notwendig um das
ziel zu erreichen
2030 darf es kein hunger auf der welt
mehr geben vielen dank
dann doch
als nächstes er das wort die kollegen
der nacht grünes bündnis 90
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie mich obwohl ich gar
nicht vorhatte so richtig auf den alle
redebeiträge eingehen mich auf herrn
stier konzentrieren und den stier bei
den hörnern packen was mir gefehlt hat
sie haben ja sehr emotional empathisch
und so und moral geredet warum ist in
ihrem redebeitrag herrscht ihr mit
keinem wort die zweite enzyklika des
papstes franziskus von 2015 erwähnt
worden laudator ziehen
das gemeinsam raus warum haben sie
darüber nicht geredet ich sage ich warum
weil sie wenn sie 2015 gesagt hätten
hier sofort an dieser stelle hätten
erklären müssen was sie aus diesem
gemeinsamen haus diesem laudato si nicht
gemacht haben nicht gemacht haben
1 20 fast 200 millionen menschen haben
akuten hunger in krisen niveau was haben
sie gemacht 21 wo waren sie woran ihre
aktivitäten oder im rahmen der korona
krise haben zusätzlich 320 millionen
menschen kein gesundes essen gehabt sie
haben 360 163 millionen menschen haben
weniger als fünf dollar am tag verdient
durch den krieg sind da noch mal 47 dazu
gekommen ich hab vermisst dass sie
gesagt haben was sie denn getan haben
hätten dann hätten sie uns vorstellen
können ihre guten dinge fortzusetzen
aber da war nichts fortzusetzen
herstellt sie reden
ja das muss man sagen wir wissen seit
langem durch konflikte durch wetter
extreme klima und wirtschaftskrisen wird
hunger ausgelöst und steht da nachhaltig
hätten sie doch mal was gemacht
stattdessen reden sie hier am ende unter
dem vorwand sich um die welternährung zu
sorgen von vielen millionen menschen
über ein belastungsmoratorium
und benennen die ökologischen
vorrangflächen deren klima und
biodiversität auswirkungen
betriebsgrundlagen der bauern sind es
bei uns für die jüngeren die benennen
sie in stilllegungsflächen um und
behaupten dann auch dass das bisschen
gewässern schreiben und anderes den
weltbürger beseitigen würde
absurd warum hat der ire ministerin
glöckler diese ganzen strategieplan für
die nächste gab genauso verabschiedet
fragen sie doch frank lettner warum da
vier prozent ökologische vorrangflächen
drin steht und das war noch ein fauler
kompromiss
ich will ihnen sagen ich will ihnen
sagen wir haben nichts zu verschenken
ich weiß dass der dbv gesagt hat der
vorschlag zum thema weizen fruchtwechsel
von cem özdemir sei der der viel mehr
bringt lassen sie uns wirklich globalen
hunger bekämpfen es gibt dazu
krisenreaktion spleen das aa das bmz das
landwirtschaftsministerium arbeiten
zusammen gegeben 430 millionen euro an
der stelle aus und ich sag mal auch wenn
sie manche schlecht reden und am ende
sagen noch mehr chemie sie haben doch in
diesem haus für ihren herrn minister
müller einen großen antrag eingebracht
das weltweit der hunger bekämpft wird
und die armut durch agrarökologie warum
reden sie dann heute das gegenteil
renate künast sprecherin für ernährung
und landwirtschaft sie war ja mal
bundesministerium für verbraucherschutz
ernährung und landwirtschaft 2001 bis
und der nächste redner max straubinger
von der csu ist landwirtschaftsmeister
in der ausbildung mitglied im ausschuss
für ernährung und landwirtschaft
rettig kolleginnen und kollegen wir
haben natürlich heute wieder eine
erhitzte debatte denn natürlich der
hunger in der welt verrückt mehr ins
blickfeld der bürgerinnen und bürger und
frau kollegin künast wenn sie jetzt aus
führen also dass produktion nicht wäre
und nicht sein soll dann frage ich mich
wie wollen sie den heraufziehenden
zusätzlichen hunger in der welt aufgrund
aufgrund des krieges aufgrund des
krieges in der ukraine bekämpfen dem
bekämpfen wir den bekämpfen wir nicht
den bekämpfen wir nicht mit zusätzlichen
geld für die welthungerhilfe sondern den
hunger in der welt bekämpfen wir mit dem
dass wir angebote nämlich
weizenerzeugung also mit tätigen nur
nur weizen beinhaltet kilokalorien zu
kalorien zu ernährung und nicht das geld
also das muss man hier mit betrachten
schon von daher gilt dass die produktion
anzukurbeln und das ist mit und das ist
bei ihnen ständig in der kritik die
ganze europäische union ist in der
verantwortung den ausfall der bedeutet
durch den kriegen der ukraine das weizen
nicht mehr noch nord afrika exportiert
werden kann einmal weil die helfend
einmal weil die häfen durch russland
blockiert werden und gleichzeitig weil
dort
kriegsgeschehen ist und jetzt sich
herausstellt dass möglicherweise zehn
bis zwölf millionen tonnen weniger
weizen sozusagen in diesen armen länder
zu
ehrung der bevölkerung hier auch mit an
landen kann das bedeutet dass die
europäische union hier einen ausgleich
schaffen muss und die europäische union
ist bereit sie hat die ökologischen
vorrangflächen für den anbau von
getreide und weizen freigegeben
deutschland ist das einzige land in der
in der europäischen union die sich hier
verweigert hat und das ist unverschämt
gegenüber den hungernden menschen in der
welt und
dasselbe trainers gilt gilt auch für die
vier prozent flächenstilllegung wir
arbeiten daran und es muss daran
gearbeitet werden dass diese vier
prozent flächenstilllegung nächstes jahr
nicht ermöglicht wird und die
europäische union da bin ich überzeugt
ist auch bereit dazu aber deutschland
ist hier der große hemmschuh
dementsprechend falls sie die verkehrte
ideologie letztendlich nachfolgen wollen
wir wollen und dementsprechend dann
nicht bereit sind den hunger in der welt
und in der nahe osten mit eine abhilfe
zu geben und wenn wir in deutschland
diese flächen frei geben dann
verniedlichen sich ständig so zu sagen
was damit produziert werden kann es kann
eine million tonnen eine million tonne
weizen produziert werden nur von
deutschland aus das sind zehn prozent
des ausfalls das sind zehn prozent des
ausfalls das ist ernährung für fünf
millionen menschen die sind ihnen wohl
gleich jetzt oder mal das ist
unverständnis sage ich ganz offen
unethisch und unmoralisch
was sie hier betreiben und deshalb
plädieren wir dafür dass diese auge auf
die tätig wird weil es wichtig ist den
hunger in der welt zu bekämpfen daher
gestorben
ich kam ja nicht dazu sie zu
unterbrechen ihr kollege schauen wir die
ganze zeit versuche ich das schon
gestanden seine inzwischen frage
vielen dank herr präsident sehr geehrter
herr kollege straubinger danke dass sie
die frage zu lassen sie haben gerade von
verniedlichung gesprochen und von den
hungernden der welt
beim zweiten sind wir bei ihnen aber
jetzt frage ich sie warum um alles in
der welt reden sie dann nicht über die
flächen die wir frei geben könnten für
den anbau von lebensmitteln die heute in
die erzeugung von agrosprit gehen acht
bis neun prozent unserer erzeugung und
warum reden sie nicht über die flächen
die wir frei geben könnten für die
erzeugung von lebensmitteln die heute zu
60 prozent 60 prozent der
getreideerzeugung in den futtertrog
gehen es kann doch nicht angehen dass
wir gutes getreide in den futtertrog
ippen staat sie den hungernden dieser
welt zu geben
lieber herr kollege ebene ich bin sehr
dankbar für diese frage weil dann kann
ich dazu auch noch einige ausführungen
tätigen ihre kolleginnen die frau
spallek hat in ihren einführenden worten
gesagt wir wollen frei sein von fonds
von fossilen energieträgern
gleichzeitig wollen sie jetzt dem
biosprit verbieten wo die frühere
landwirtschaftsministerin künast einmal
dargelegt hat dass die bauern die
zukünftigen öl teig sein werden also was
wollen sie was wollen sie was wollen sie
ich glaube die beimischung ist ein
wichtiges element co2 sparsam
letztendlich alter hier die fahrzeuge zu
betreiben abgesehen davon dies
wesentlich einen höheren effekt hat in
der co2 freien oder neutralen umsetzung
ist wie ihr viel gepriesenes tempolimit
auf den autobahnen sollte man auch der
medizin also hier haben wir als auch
beste chancen und es ist auch weiterhin
wichtig die beimischung mit zu tätigen
abgesehen davon sie können nicht
behaupten dass alle pflanzen sozusagen
für die ernährung wichtig sind müssen
sie 4,9 millionen hektar wiese und
grasland in unserem land das bedeutet
fleischproduktion durch rinderhaltung
die brauchen auch die brauchen auch die
3d letztendlich also für die zusätzliche
ernährung herr kollege ebner also
drucken hören sie auf mit dem unnützen
diskussion teller oder tank kürzer mal
beziehungsweise teller oder trug also
das kannst du nicht wirklich sein
sondern es ist wichtig dass hier die
landwirtschaftliche produktion auf einem
hohen level gehoben wird das trägt ein
bei den hunger in der welt zu bekämpfen
fertigt kolleginnen
deshalb deshalb fordern wir dass die
stilllegung sprechen die angedachten
stilllegungsflächen zukünftig auch
bewirtschaftet werden können und frau
spallek sie haben da auch ausgeführt und
das ist finde ich wirklich gelinde
gesagt einfach eine falschdarstellung
die sie geben in diesen sie haben ja
plädiert dafür dass diese flächen nicht
freigegeben werden das sind aber nicht
flächen mit hacken und sonstige sind
sondern das sind flächen die derzeit in
der bewirtschaftung sind in der
landwirtschaftlichen bewirtschaftung und
sie zeichnen ein falsches bild gegenüber
den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
deutschland und das ist infam und so
geht's nicht weiter wird soll man mit
dieser darstellung
deshalb
deshalb empfehle ich ihnen
viele mittel dem welternährungsprogramm
zu geben aber gleichzeitig auch die
entsprechend die ware die damit gekauft
werden kann und tatsächlich den hunger
in der welt zu bekämpfen herzlicher dank
für die aufmerksamkeit stimmen sie
unserem antrag zu vielen dank herr
kollege straubinger
als nächster redner das wort die
kollegin sylvia lehmann spd fraktion
die helfer präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der cdu csu
letzte woche habe ich und ich gebe dazu
mit ein wenig bedauern ihren antrag zur
zusätzlichen aufstockung des globalen
treuhandfonds für nutzpflanzen viel zeit
abgelehnt nun legen sie uns einen antrag
zur ernährungssicherheit vor ihr antrag
tritt die sorge der
nahrungsmittelversorgung wir alle teilen
diese sorge beim flüssigen lesen des
antrages beschleicht mich allerdings die
sorge und auch eine sorge dass sie alles
und vieles wollen nur keine entwicklung
mein eindruck ist mit dem antrag
benutzen sie die krise um
transformationsprozesse rückgängig zu
machen genau die prozesse die ihre
fraktion auch in den letzten jahrzehnten
schon ausgegrenzt hat
und insofern klingt es schon mutig wenn
sie nun von der jetzigen bundesregierung
eine krisenfeste
europäische und deutsche landwirtschaft
fordern
am montag gab es diesem antrag eine
anhörung mit fachexperten im
fachausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
bis auf einen waren sich alle einig dass
die meisten ihrer führung zu kurz
greifen wenn sie uns anschließend in
dieser pressemitteilung vorwerfen
ausgerechnet die ampel regierung würde
die agrarpolitische zeitwende verhindern
waren sie entweder auf einer anderen
veranstaltung oder die anhörung lag und
liegt ihnen schwer im magen
wieder zulegen kollegen alle
sachverständigen stimmten darin überein
dass die globale ernährungskrise bereits
lange vor dem angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine bestand dass die ursachen für
hunger in der welt nicht zu geringe ag
hat adra erträge sind sondern bewaffnete
kriege klimawandel armut und
ungleichheit dass der ukraine krieg vor
allem ein preisgibt rät mit profiteuren
ist gegen den eine steigerung der
landwirtschaftlichen
produktion rein gar nichts ausrichten
kann dass wir die nutzung von getreide
als dieseltreibstoff und futtermittel
reduzieren müssen dass wir spekulationen
auf
lebensmittelpreise durch sanktionen
strafen und transparenz entgegenwirken
müssen dass ihr die abhängigkeit ärmere
länder von unseren exporten reduzieren
und ihnen einen höheren
selbstversorgungsgrad ermöglichen und
und dass wir vor allem die biodiversität
weltweit steigern müssen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die anhörung
hat uns eines gelehrt die debatte zur
welternährung müssen wir viel breiter
führen dabei geht es nicht nur um den
anteil vom anbau von weizen oder roggen
und angesichts der komplexität erscheint
mir die diskussion des ja oder nein zur
freigabe der vier prozent praktischen
für das thema einfach verfehlt da
brachflächen wichtige funktionen für den
wasserhaushalt sowie für die flora und
faune abfüllen wäre der biologische
schaden hier größer als der agrar
ökonomische nutzen so die experten
selbstverständlich nehmen wir in der
koalition die weltweite lage infolge des
angriffskrieges gegen die ukraine sehr
ernst neben direkten hilfen für alle vom
krieg betroffenen menschen setzen wir
uns auch für eine wirksame sicherung der
globalen nahrungsmittelversorgung 1 die
bundesregierung hat bereits auf die
verknappung von futtermitteln
insbesondere ökologischen bereich
reagiert dieses jahr darf der aufwuchs
auf ökologischen vorrangflächen
tierfutter zwecke genutzt werden
sogar der deutsche bauernverband lobte
zudem die aussetzung der pflicht zum
fruchtwechsel für ein jahr es sei die
entscheidende weil schnell wirkende
große maßnahme zur globalen
versorgungssicherung da auf guten
standorten die berichte standorten die
bodenqualität nicht leidet wenn weizen
zweimal nacheinander angebaut wird ich
empfehle ihnen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der
cdu/csu-fraktion einfach nochmal in die
anhörung reinzuschauen der bundestag
bietet das an
die beschlüsse der g 7 vom 14 mai sind
in ihrer konsequenz
wesentlich weitreichender als ihre
forderung im antrag und die debatte hat
das mir jedenfalls lieber mal sehr
deutlich gemacht wir lehnen ihren antrag
ab und wir werden unseren
transformationsprozess weiter fortsetzen
weil wir das tun müssen ich danke vielen
dank
letzter redner in dieser debatte das war
sylvia lehmann von der spd
und jetzt der letzte redner in der
debatte ist gero clemens hopfner von der
fdp es landwirtschaftspolitische
sprecher seiner fraktion
unumwunden hier an dieser stelle für
meine fraktion dass wir es für falsch
halten an dem festzuhalten was unter
anderem auch die von der cdu/csu
getragen die bundesregierung der letzten
legislaturperiode mitverhandelt hat
nämlich vier prozent der
landwirtschaftlichen flächen stilllegen
zu wollen das halte ich falsch in
friedenszeiten das halte ich in
kriegszeiten er ist rechts für falsch
deswegen sage ich ihnen auch ganz
ausdrücklich dass die koalitionäre in
dieser frage sich nicht einig sind und
dass wir noch als bei demokraten
überzeugungsarbeit leisten müssen aber
mir ist es deutlich lieber wenn die
menschen da draußen erkennen wo die
einzelnen schwerpunkten uns leider auch
manchmal die meinungsunterschiede liegen
als ein wischiwaschi wo man meint aber
alles sozusagen dem deckmantel des
schweigens zu bereiten es ist richtig
meine sehr fern und herren das hier an
dieser stelle auch einmal unterschiede
deutlich werden damit die menschen
wissen bei wem sie bei welcher position
seine kollegen noch belegen
und ich sehe nur eins an dieser stelle
mal ganz deutlich sagen es hat in den
letzten sechs monaten
seit bestehen dieser bundesregierung
nicht einen einzigen
gesetzgeberischen
nationalstaatlichen alleingang gegeben
und das ist ein wohltuender kontrast zu
insektenschutz paketen zu
nutztierhaltungsverordnung und vielen
andere initiativen der letzten
wahlperiode verehrte kolleginnen
kollegen die immer nur einen effekt
haben und zwar die produktionsstandards
innerhalb europas immer zu lasten der
landwirte in deutschland zu verschieben
und es ist gut und es ist richtig dass
diese politik endlich ein ende hat
fertig kollegin unterlegen
drittens wir werden in den kommenden
dreieinhalb jahren das baugesetzbuch
endlich überarbeiten weil es doch nicht
sein kann dass es betriebe da draußen
gibt die gerne investieren möchten
kommunen aber überhaupt nicht in der
lage sind eine genehmigung zu erteilen
auch das ist das ergebnis der letzten 16
jahre meine damen und herren wir werden
planungs und investitionssicherheit
schaffen wir werden endlich eine
europaweite haltungs und
herkunftskennzeichnung einführen weil es
doch nicht sein kann dass nicht der
verbraucher immer wieder so gerne hinter
dem argument versteckt er könne ja nicht
erkennen wo das ziel gehalten wurde
forst geschlachtet wurde wie es
verarbeitet wurde meine damen und herren
zur wahrheit und klarheit gehört auch
dazu dass wir über endlich transparenz
hergestellt wird und dass sich der
verbraucher der die hauptverantwortung
trägt hinter seinen argumenten nicht
mehr verstecken kann er wüsste gar nicht
woher das das lebewesen wo das lebewesen
gelebt hat wo es geschlachtet wurde
meine damen und herren es
ist in diesem hause und auch draußen
glaube ich niemandem verborgen geblieben
und auch die heutige debatte zeigt dass
er deutlich dass die union und das mache
ich jetzt wirklich konstruktiv in ihre
richtung
noch mit sich ringt welche rolle sie in
der landwirtschaftspolitik in der
opposition eingehen soll das meine ich
jetzt nicht despektierlich aber sie
müssen für sich die entscheidung treffen
ob sie
konstruktiv bestimmte dinge die ich
vielleicht auch eben aufgehört habe
begleiten wollen konstruktiv mitarbeiten
wollen interesse und landwirtschaft oder
ob sie weiterhin mit verschränkten armen
in der ecke sitzen wollen und darüber
frustriert sein wollen dass das was ich
eben aufgezählt habe sie in 16 jahren
nicht hinbekommen vielen dank
vielen dank für die unter georg damit
schließe ich die aussprache
wurde zunächst auf 14.000 14 tage kommt
zur beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses
für ernährung landwirtschaft
sowie waren teil der fraktion der
cdu/csu mit dem titel die der ukraine
jetzt und in zukunft helfen der ausritte
versorgung in der welt sicherstellen
sowie europäische und deutsche
landwirtschaft krisenfest gestalten der
ausschuss empfiehlt in einer
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 1880
den antrag der fraktion der cdu/csu auf
drucksache 1336 abzulehnen die
fraktionen der cdu/csu hat namentliche
abstimmung verlangt